spécialité voilà est-ce qu'on peut le
teindre les sourcils
va te faire c'est sa spécialité vous
voulez y aller tu peux m'enlever le
petit départ
les sourcils un peu plus épais parce que
ça regarde est-ce que tu peux aller tu
vas revenir tu vas partir avec lui tu
vas revenir à 19h15 à 19h dans 10
minutes tu lui fais les sourcils c'est
super propre
[Applaudissements]
j'aimerais d'abord que Kelly rentre et
après elle va nous montrer son travail
avec Mathieu c'est parti merci parce
qu'elle a
[Applaudissements]
dites-nous quel est ce que vous avez
fait à Mathieu alors j'ai débroussaillé
le sourcil d'accord
[Rires]
j'ai fait une coloration permanente déjà
bien sûr ouais ouais j'ai laissé poser 5
minutes ça suffit comme il est blond et
que votre couleur à vous elle est assez
foncée la carnation elle a juste à poser
seulement 5 minutes donc c'est très
intéressant comme produit que vous avez
dans votre loge et ensuite on a un petit
peu essuyé le tout on a brossé tout ça
vers l'extérieur pour ouvrir le regard
et je trouve que la structure du
maquillage il est mieux au niveau du
maquillage il est mieux aussi et on a
mis une petite veste on s'est permis de
la prendre dans votre garde-robe et
voilà alors il peut tout de suite
enlever la veste non mais qui viennent
sur la veste je vous dis c'est pas le
blouson noir qui était avec le r là non
voyons c'est quoi on sait ce dont on
peut se permettre
un petit truc de
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
tu sais quoi il est pas mal hein je
pense que tu étais foutu de ma gueule
j'adore ce qu'elle m'a fait là
tu veux que je te dis stop tu vas passer
des weekends avec moi des weekends
beauté et tu sais pourquoi j'ai des
petits boutons ici alors tout expliquer
des crèmes de luxe sauf que dans le luxe
c'est pas bon pour toutes les peaux et
Mathieu a une peau sensible
donc c'est pas tout le luxe il y a du
luxe avec des plantes et des fleurs et
les plantes et les fleurs c'est trop
agressives pour une peau sensible
tu peux me remercier s'il te plaît merci
s'il te plaît merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]